that's the sound of the exhaust system
of the new audi s4 the s4 is powered by
a newly revamped supercharged 3 liter
TFSI v6 engine that all adds up to
increased performance and torque the s4
is also lighter and more fuel-efficient
than previous models the engine has a
power output of 260 kilowatts and even
at a relatively low 1370 revs it can
reach a maximum torque of 500 Newton
meters ps4 leaps from 0 to 100 km/h in
just 4.7 seconds and uses an average of
seven point three liters of fuel for 100
kilometers hundred Samoan says the s4
has a great sound but that's not the
only thing about this car that's
appealing to the senses English bakken
bed that's where our house finding the
s4 is also a good-looking car and it
features an efficient 8-speed Tiptronic
transmission for responsive gear changes
you can switch to freewheeling mode to
save fuel
the matrix LED headlights are another
standout feature available as an option
for 1,900 euros in Germany
bs4 is also available as a station wagon
dalmore tahia death and raises the s 4's
engine is really powerful you can feel
it and hear it when you step on the gas
but there's a certain smoothness to it
all this makes for a really pleasant
driving experience that is vocations
eranga names heart of food
anthon and ray says the s4 appeals to
the senses in other ways to a status
thing define gabite in China here the
dashboard has a nice design it's easy to
use and its pleasant to the touch and
then there's that distinctive howdy
clicking sound on some of the controls
and for Heinz the cottage
demo mystics dozen undraped points out
that the s4 has several visual features
that drivers will appreciate people used
to check the speedometer regularly on
Susan wish nominees mittal available
nowadays they also keep an eye on that
sat nav that's right Natasha howdy point
of one's commander Schmidt in virtual
cockpit the s4 is virtual cockpit offers
navigation data plus standard info like
fuel remaining mileage and speed you can
even make a phone call or check for the
latest traffic updates it's all there on
a high-definition screen società the
twelve point three inch virtual cockpit
made its debut in 2014 in the Audi TT
and is now also available in Audis a4
model line in Germany this system costs
about three thousand three hundred euros
including the multimedia interface
the front sports seats offer improved
comfort and support Madame s via Andre
says the s4 is a sport higher version of
the a4 and it's a real treat for the
senses the suggested starting price for
the basic model is just under sixty
thousand euros andre's only complaint is
that you have to pay extra for options
like the matrix LED headlights and the
virtual cockpit vidas matrix LED list on
this virtual cockpit a man half price
custom as far as performance is
concerned the s4 can compete effectively
with similar models like the porsche
boxster and cayman that's clear from the
s4 s engine stats and you can hear that
performance when you put the s4 through
its paces
Portia unveiled the next generation Ford
or gran turismo Panamera with a
spectacular stage show as 5,000 car test
armata Scott remembers being at the auto
shanghai in 2009 when the first
connemara was debuted it was an attempt
to broaden Porsches appeal but it met
widespread skepticism those critics have
since taken a backseat since seven years
on here's the second generation in terms
of design it's not that different from
the first overall it has a cleaner look
but the most obvious innovation is at
the rear Pythia gabba Thesz mutters
karad explains this like bar strip was
previously only on the 911 four-wheel
drive model the hatch is larger changing
the rears overall look and of course the
rear is what most people are going by
seeing of the new Panamera on the
Autobahn did I [ __ ] out not surprisingly
for Porsche its goal with the 2nd gen
Panamera was to design the sportiest
vehicle in the luxury sedan segment to
start it offers a choice of three
engines to gasoline powered and one 310
kilowatt v8 diesel best actor the
panamera turbo has the most powerful
gasoline-powered engine of the series
with four liters capacity eight
cylinders and two turbochargers mounted
inside the cylinder block and even more
powerful engine is soon to follow in the
Panamera Turbo S a spin around the
Nurburgring legendary north loop is
proof positive of the 404 kilowatt twin
turbocharged engines performance
reaching top speeds of 306 km/h the
Panamera completed a lap in seven
minutes and 38 seconds it's even faster
than the last generation 911 turbo
mastectomy lane test driver Lars can
explains its long wheelbase makes
cornering smoother and the rear axle
steering and active rule stabilization
makes it feel unexpectedly agile even at
lower speeds that's really what sets the
Panamera apart this is a nice discuss
medium my sinful wounded at the motto an
amazing big guys that are very soon it
about to tell there's nothing unexpected
about its interiors sleek and stylish
look it combines Porsches trademark
luxury with sophisticated technology
why not that's a Mattoon the look of the
dashboard is an obvious nod to the first
generation says matas kirat but the
technology is state-of-the-art to the
left and right of the proper analog
tachometer are 27 inch displays showing
speed for example along with various
other functions on the right you can
switch between navigation night vision
all the features you'd expect from a
Porsche have you got Shawn Knox East
Alice Merkley here versus hides or in
einem whoa dance part of our stuff in
housing gift German Hollywood star Ralph
Miller was at the premiere in late June
and says the car feels tailor-made for
him nearly two meters tall he weighs a
hundred and twenty kilos so he likes a
car with plenty of legroom this one's
perfect gun stoat it's a deluxe ride not
only for the driver says mattes the
Panamera offers both the performance of
a sports car and the comfort of a luxury
sedan with generous space in back like
in the front the control system is
modeled on the smartphone and as he
points out tall passengers don't need to
worry about bumping their heads Lucilla
mention having p applause as a goober
mine cop fear that is not lovely utilize
starting at a cool one hundred thirteen
thousand euros in Germany the new
Panamera can already be ordered now but
deliveries won't begin until November
opals new zafira will be appearing on
showroom floors in October the interior
features opals familiar flex seven
seating system the exterior is sporty-er
and the front redesigned the Zafira has
taken on some design elements from its
little brother the Opel Astra it starts
at a list price under 22 thousand euros
in Germany Germany's introducing cash
incentives designed to bring electric
cars out of the niche market they've
been wedged into so far at the same time
car manufacturers are working hard to
extend battery range previously the
Nissan Leaf could run 200 kilometres on
a charge a new battery has been
introduced with the 30 kilowatt hour
capacity good for about 250 kilometres
earlier this year the honda jazz was
rated one of europe's safest cars based
on the results of tests carried out by
the euro and cap program we thought we'd
take a closer look at the Jazz one of
the criteria used in the crash tests is
the performance of the car's driver
assists the Honda Jazz offers the city
emergency brake assistant the Jazz
features a new longer platform and a
wider wheel base it's not very big just
over 3.8 meters long but the current
model has a lot more room inside than
before the taillights sort of look like
they belong on a Volvo the third brake
light has been integrated into the
spoiler
the interior looks a lot roomier you can
choose the new infotainment option Honda
connect you can also run the system from
buttons on the steering wheel
the cup holders to the left of the
steering column are an especially
welcome addition the center console is
chock full of goodies including a
12-volt outlet and hdmi and USB ports
auto tester and Manuel Schaefer is going
to show us the back seat area ah there's
plenty of room back here plenty of room
for your needs and it's comfortable too
that's important for long trips so a
clean baby if you don't have to worry
about passengers you can fold up the
back seat to create a big storage area
there's enough room for small items of
furniture or even a bike semester [ __ ]
Lana como uno de rahi nothing gettin fat
Italian but now Emmanuel is going to
show us the trunk there's 350 litres of
space here ah that's pretty big there's
even enough room to sit down and there
should be plenty of space for all your
shopping site but if you need more room
just flip a couple of switches to create
even more space to 1300 liters in fact
you haven't F that's kansas ain't
laughing
so let's see how the Jazz performs on
the road Honda has introduced a new
platform and chassis and that gives the
car a more dynamic field plus they've
reduced its overall weight and increased
body stability this model of the Jazz
comes only with the 1.3 liter petrol
engine
but a man will points out that you can
choose from two transmissions a 6-speed
manual or a continuously variable
transmission CVT the Honda Jazz can go
from 0 to 100 km/h in just over 11
seconds it can reach a top speed of 190
km/h and as far as fuel efficiency is
concerned the Jazz gets 100 kilometers
on five liters of gas in cult off Iman
well says the Jazz handles pretty well
on the road and it holds the line
comfortably through corners the engines
a little low on torque so it takes you a
while to notice the change after you
shifted years Texas mission from for
treatment for all Emmanuel has mixed
feelings about the honda jazz its design
reminds him a lot of the Civic but
that's just a matter of personal taste a
motor the engines not very powerful
particularly under 3,000 rpm Leland
dhafra but the Jazz is pretty room
whether you're sitting in the back seat
or eluding a bunch of stuff into the
truck and you can even have more space
by reconfiguring the seats that's one of
the cars big advantages
the price for the honda jazz in germany
is just under sixteen thousand euros and
if you include all the options that we
did in our test model plus a few extras
the price could easily top twenty
thousand
Marketing divisions have been known to
come up with some off-the-wall ideas to
attract customers such as combining two
apparently unrelated and even
incompatible things
when the deeper enna gate car tester
Sasha [ __ ] describes the Jeep renegade
as just such a combination a pizza
burger totally American on the outside
and old-world Italian inside not the
Ferrari or Lamborghini kind of Italian
but like it's close relative the Fiat
500x being built in Melfi Italy doesn't
mean cuts in quality after all fiat
started building cars in the early 20th
century over 40 years before Jeep did